[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome to swipe the gamespot mobile
showcase hosted by me greg miller now
you may know me as the game awards 2015
trending gamer co-founder of kind of
funny but most importantly i'm a former
ign employee
that's right everybody i played the long
game i won and now i'm hosting a
gamespot show
me right here now you might be asking
greg what is swipe and why should i care
about it well swipe is another one of
those video game showcases that we all
love but since jeff keeley has cornered
the market on showcases that are stuffed
full of big beautiful video games we
decided to go the other way and show a
little love to mobile games after all
we're all playing them
these days mobile games are as creative
and lovingly crafted as the games we
play on our consoles pcs and handhelds
there's a special kind of magic to them
because i don't know about you but to me
there's nothing quite like sneaking in
some puzzle quest 3 or a couple of
begudging boards of peggle blast because
the original more superior peggle is no
longer available
get your act together
anyways regardless of the title mobile
games meet you where you are and offer
you a variety of engaging and satisfying
gaming experiences and that's pretty
damn cool if you ask me this is going to
be a reminder of the unique joys that
mobile games offer we're also going to
crown the greatest mobile game of all
time during this show for the last few
weeks you've been voting on what game
you think should take the throne and
we'll unveil the winner soon you're
going to get a good look at what the
future holds for the gaming platforms
you keep in your pocket now kurt and
tamar are supposed to be here helping me
present but i have no idea where they
are and i'm a busy man with a wwe show
on peacock so i'm just gonna kick this
thing off with our first trailer
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i feel like we're supposed to be
somewhere right now but i cannot
remember where yeah well i know where
i'm supposed to be in middle earth on
every single screen available to me how
are you watching two towers watching the
trailer for the game listening to lo-fi
middle-earth beats at the same time did
you um did you know that when viggo
kicked that helmet he really broke his
tail
the scream was real
you're obsessed
a new ring
how did it come to you
why
did it choose you
heroes of middle earth is the
free-to-play turn-based strategy rpg
that brings together an endless
assortment of classic characters from
the tolkien universe in a strategic
social competitive mobile experience the
new ring very interesting aspect of our
game what the ring does is it grants the
player the ability to bring the best
characters the characters that he feels
best suit that battle that's going to
happen in that location
and somewhat you know push the bounds of
what is the narrative cannon and allow
for the players to sort of experience
things in a new and fresh way but within
the larger story that we're presenting
and the larger sort of conceit within
the game it will make much more sense
once players dive into it this ring will
will of course be a big part of that
there's such a depth of storytelling to
use in such a way that combines both
narrative and gameplay mechanics so
players are constantly challenging new
and surprising ways that's a big part of
why we chose to expand the narrative in
our game both to serve the familiar
stories
but also intertwine them with gameplay
design in a way that will keep the game
fun and imaginative over time you've
seen frodo you've seen sam you've seen
legolas that's only a really small
sampling of course you know some of the
most iconic characters we have
characters that range from you know the
entire timeline from all of those
stories
and we've also expanded out
uh races and factions within that so
players can really experience them in a
way that they probably haven't to
to date our combat is turn-based
strategy players can hone their skills
across the game
using the story mode and pvp mode they
can design teams around unique combat
skills and abilities to win battles and
they can also play to character
relationships and personalities to
unlock team-ups and
synergy bonuses reinforcing friendships
families and rivalries i would describe
our art style as a form of stylized
realism but what that means for us is
that we have characters and environments
that are simplified
they're not caricatured
they're grounded but they're quite
fantastic if you go back even further
you know our art style is actually quite
close to the original ip tolkien's own
original watercolor illustrations of
middle earth are
very bright they're very colorful
they're heavily stylized
and we take that as a point of
inspiration it's interesting developing
the art style with some characters who
have very little written about them
you know how does one do that we take a
race we take a faction like uh herodrim
who have some things written about them
you can come up with details but how do
we realize that into something that we
feel is unique and appealing at the same
time we do that a lot by simply making
sure that that the style is something
clear and legible it's going to read
really well on a mobile device we are
not ready quite yet to share our
worldwide launch timeline just yet but
players should stay tuned as we continue
our soft launch rollout and select
countries around the world
our next batch of games includes one
that comes from nexon it's a beautiful
turn-based strategy game with rpg hooks
that looks like it was made for consoles
but actually will be playable in the
palm of your hand it's got more than 300
playable and collectible characters each
with their own unique abilities and
there's a gorgeous 3d anime visual style
nexon also has a kart racing game called
kart rider drift which you can check out
some fresh gameplay for and if none of
that tickles your fancy how about new
content for a cozy puzzle game about
laying out train tracks for adorable dog
people to drive and direct
trust me it looks great
[Music]
very well let us begin
explain yourself
[Music]
so what shall we do with this one sir
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
triple kill
roger kill
unstoppable
[Music]
[Music]
railbound is a comfy puzzle game about
connecting trains on a journey around
the world
together with your canine companions you
will pass through shortcuts pick up cute
passengers and solve over 100 puzzles
railbound has just launched on the app
store and google play and we'd be
thrilled if you gave it a try especially
since we'll keep expanding the game in
2022
aside from fixes and accessibility
updates later this year you can expect
new puzzles new worlds and a brand new
mechanic
semaphores thanks to these placeable
obstacles you'll be able to delay
carriages and solve even more twisted
puzzles
thanks for tuning in and enjoy the rest
of the showcase
[Music]
what are you doing there
playing streets of rage 4 developed and
published by emu lizard cube and god
crush games okay that was uh weirdly a
lot of information um
do you have to play it so loudly listen
if you were supportive friend instead of
berating me you'd be helping me tame the
rage on these streets it's a single
player game damn
is it cur
is it
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
hey siri send a message to curtin tam
where are you guys
we told them 10 am right
mobile game stores can be overwhelming
but apple has made significant progress
in offering a curated experience through
apple arcade the subscription service
gives members access to the best of the
best when it comes to mobile games on
ios whether it's classics like angry
birds new takes on games you already
love like frogger or brilliant brand new
experiences like assemble with care
fantasian or lego builder's journey
there's plenty for you to get obsessed
with take a look at new footage of
horizon chase 2 garden tales match and
grow and shovel knight dig all coming to
apple arcade later this month and fans
of asphalt 8 plus mini motorways and
what the golf can also look forward to
those games among others getting updates
soon
[Music]
horizon chase 2 is an evolution of the
franchise our main challenge was to make
a sequel without losing its original
essence the arcade racing spirit the
unique art style and the signature
gameplay that made it such a success
this junior
creating the design of our cars was one
of the most important parts of the
production many things inspired us in
this process like the automotive design
industry or the country that the car
represents we also worked with amazing
designers who did a great job helping us
develop these cars that are in fact the
main characters of horizon chase two
jobs
a simple pick up and play you go
straight to the fun especially on
networking
um
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
maximals
[Music]
through
[Music]
what an amazing race
[Music]
you're either born cool or you're not
[Applause]
[Music]
bye bye bad guys
that was the most exciting thing i've
ever done
[Music]
on the way
[Music]
[Music]
you know
i'm starting to think like we are
supposed to be somewhere right now
this hideo kojima guy's got some
interesting ideas
oh no
we've got text from greg
we're supposed to beat the swipe
showcase right now we're late
he says i've already reached the part of
the showcase where we show off gameplay
for the division resurgence the new game
from ubisoft that brings the tactical
multiplayer action of its console and pc
titles to mobile and that the new
clubhouse map will be in the rainbow six
beta
snow way
how are we still making snow based
division jokes in 2022
we have to go
take him out
the division resurgence in the
lore is starting right before the
division one event and then you will
have the bulk of the content after the
division one basically between the
division one and the division so that's
like brand new
stories but totally consistent with what
has been set in the division one and the
division two the the division resurgence
is
set in new york city one of the
objective was to come back to the vibe
of the division one that was very strong
and loved by the community it's always a
great experience to to get you know
familiar things that you wish to explore
seeing through the length of the game
for example we have the full mission on
liberty island you see the statue of
liberty from afar it feels like a known
place but for us it was very important
to come back to the roots of the game
actually
on target we just had our first close
alpha and it's very interesting to see
that people reacted quite positively of
the fact that it's a true mmo in the
sense that you can
meet real players
while exploring the open world not only
in the state's place but also in the
middle of the street and
and to have some some very interesting
encounters i was
also surprised to see that some people
were happy to see that their character
was actually speaking now i'll kill
every last one here
the division resurgence class system
there will be six classes in that first
alpha we did introduce three of them
which which are the demolitionists and
the whole walk
and the goal is really to find synergies
when you're playing cooperation in teams
so with the with the demolitionist it's
basically the heavy gun a large
area of effect and and you can basically
engage
the enemies in groups and and try to fix
them on specific spots
you have the ball walk which is more
like a tank melee where you can with
your shield go in close quarter use your
shotgun and try to take advantage and
basically
get the intention of the
enemies while you're progressing you can
start to tune
each
skills each specific power of those
classes to to get very specific on what
you're doing
what are the difference between the
division one and
the division two first it's free
consistent but it's like a brand new
story uh and we're adding new stuff like
uh new factions with the freeman new
heroes new vlans and and also additional
classes that bring something new to the
recipe but staying very true to what is
a division
[Music]
when are we gonna learn more about the
division resurgence you will learn what
are the next stage what are we cooking
for you at the ubisoft ford on september
10th
bounce of cover
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
operators let's move in and register now
as a renowned voice actor i am capable
of doing many many accents but i'm
particularly skilled at the british
accent this next game will probably
feature many british voices saying
things like oh my god
that soul look real sharp in it please
say can i have a bigger shield and not
to be outdone the question is bro what
can you do love
here's an update on medieval 2 total war
[Music]
[Applause]
so
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
cam
the car is almost here we got to go
you've been in there for ages i'm just
in the middle of a run
i didn't even know that
i said aeron not the runs
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dangerous
[Music]
you might know netflix as the movie and
tv streaming service you use to entice
people into hookups under the pretense
of chilling but did you know that they
do video games now too in fact they just
recently released a new version of
critically acclaimed strategy game into
the breach and it is awesome they also
put out point p from the makers of down
well it's down well but upwards anyway
the point being netflix is getting into
mobile games in a big way here are a few
new games you can look forward to
including lucky luna which surprise you
can play right now
there's also desta the new game from the
creators of monument valley
now where are these guys
still no word
it's late now
so in the game what you do is you play
the role of dester who's a young person
in their early 20s who's coming back
home to their family home after not
being there for a few years when they
get back they've got a couple of
conflicts with their mother and with
some family and with friends that
they're really struggling to find the
words to say to try and resolve those
things their dad who unfortunately isn't
there anymore he used to be the person
who would help them find the words by
throwing this ball back and forth in
their backyard so when daster grabs this
ball and and falls to sleep with it they
find themselves between these two worlds
of awakened asleep being able to explore
their their dreams their memories some
of these conflicting conversations and
through throwing the ball and dodging
things and making the right plays
hopefully they'll find the words to say
to try and resolve some of these
conflicts desta is a turn-based tactics
game a bit like a board game you take it
in terms with your team and the enemy
team and each turn you have a set amount
of action points that you can use to
play the game and it rolls around dodge
ball so each action point you kind of
use to pick up and throw the ball to try
and defeat the enemy team in the game
we're using that as a metaphor for
conversations conversations are turn
based and we've turned that into like a
turn-based ball game where when i have
the ball that's sort of me saying what i
really want to say and throwing it to
you and then you will like take a hit
when you throw the ball
it can bounce in a way that you don't
expect it makes you reconsider your
tactics you can't play it like chess you
have to be more flexible about like
figuring out and changing your tactics
on the go we wanted to be able to have a
bit more of a fun mechanic for less
experienced players to really latch onto
so then we settled on this this ball
throwing which really allows the player
to perform trick shots like bounce
things around corners use special
abilities and various kind of team
setups every unit has its own ability
and that's where the sort of tactical
strategic elements come into play some
powers work really well with each other
and some synergise really well and it's
up to the players to sort of
explore and try out things and see how
their own play style tends to emerge
from like maybe you're more offensive
like me and you want to just have all
the sort of abilities that do lots of
damage or maybe you want to be just
moving around the map and you pick more
like traversal-based abilities and just
try and like dominate in terms of like
getting access to all the balls my
favorite ability in the game recently we
have introduced like mirror image which
creates a decoy of your desktop it
tricks the ai to attack the decoy which
gives you more possibilities because
like you can't drop a decoy here and
just run through the other side of the
map and while the enemies are still
looking at this decoy you can grab the
ball in their field throughout the game
you're unlocking items known as memoria
which are relics from their past or
items that have some sort of
significance to them that grant them a
power in the game hand vacuum is my
favorite memorial so when you walk near
a ball but you're not on the tile it
sucks up the ball to your character one
of my favorite levels in the game this
little dead end road this kind of like
end of a cul-de-sac kind of feeling
location the level really makes the most
out of that idea of passing to get
behind this character who's putting
obstruction in your face you can't just
throw the ball straight at them in order
to get them out you've got to either
pass to your friend and hit the back of
them or you've got a ricochet off the
back wall or off a hedge row i like to
try and pick allies who have
powers that synergise well james who has
the teleportation ability lets him go
anywhere on the map but it does come at
the expense of all of his action points
fortunately there's a support character
called miss k
whose ability is to gift an ap to
another player so that lets you do cool
things with james like teleport behind
enemy lines and then take a throw or
grab one of the balls it's definitely
the deepest game that we've ever
developed in terms of game mechanics and
player expression and play styles and
it's also specifically designed to be
multi-platform
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
oh god what's wrong greg is fine don't
worry about it
hey greg how's it going no the question
you should be asking is what am i doing
and the answer is all of it you were
supposed to be here ages ago greg calm
down uofl people should know that remote
work is how we get things done these
days you can do anything from anywhere
for example watch this we'll do this
transition from the back of this uber
tumble time is the new game coming from
devolver the quirky folks behind stuff
like call of the lamb and hotline miami
and it's expected to release sometime in
early 2023 we've also got tower of
fantasy for anime enjoyers like me and
cookie run for cookie enjoyers like me
and tower of god great journey which is
finally coming to north america and
europe and has pre-registration opening
in october a lot of games in and around
towers right now yeah
see you soon greg bye got this under
control it's
fine pick up your phone it's tumble time
revolver
[Music]
this game saved my marriage
[Music]
tumble time a for-profit game
ready
go devolver tumble time it's all of your
favorite devolver digital characters
made adorable in the pursuit of profit
and it's free we had to get a little
weird with it though but we'll let you
find that out for yourself
tumble time is a physics-based
match-free game each level has its own
goals and challenges to focus on at the
expense of your own real life goals and
challenges detonate explosives work
yourself into a high scoring fever mode
use items you clod just go bananas and
the game will reward you with stuff
make leveling up your devolver digital
character into your new life's work so
that you can unlock more of all the
digital characters that you can then
level up each with their own special
abilities but that's not all
we crammed a whole bunch of junk into
tumble time that you're flipping love
daily challenges where you can flex your
skills weekly maps with boss fights and
a mysterious quest given to you by
everyone's favorite cfo fork parker i
approve this message get ready to dust
off all your favorite devolver digital
characters and put them to work now
someone please get that dashed song out
of my head
tumble time tumble time pick up your
phone it's tumble
[Music]
squander your precious time on earth
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to pharah a new
expansion of power fantasy our latest
open world mmrpg launched last month
now we hold a studio are excited to give
you a sneak peek at mirori the hub city
of the new expansion
mirroria is a massive new island located
in the heart of the desert
in miroria wanderers will be able to
explore a cool cyberpunk themed city
while enjoying the awesome view
one neat thing about muroria is its
transportation method to get around each
areas in the area you can hop on this
cool futuristic taxi or ride on a train
that runs through the air so make sure
you utilize those when you get around
otherwise you might run out of endurance
mid-air and might end up dying
there are also many other interesting
places for you to visit such as museum
and bar
so make sure you check out all those
places
that's all i have for you today but
please make sure you stay tuned for more
information about the upcoming update of
tower fantasy
[Music]
there's only one thing to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
i'm
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
captain caviar cookie
he dared to explore the treacherous
waters of the dusk gloom sea to unravel
a mystery
relentless waves under the lead and sky
and something unknown
awaiting below the depths
how did captain caviar cookie escape
from the abyss
an unexpected ally from the sea bottom
candy diver cookie will be joining the
cookie run kingdom crew
oh and don't forget to meet the adorable
disney friends who are visiting the
cookie kingdom to enjoy the festival of
dreams and wishes
and hey wink wink there's another
crossover in the works
so stay tuned because you're in for a
great surprise
up next a closer look at brick city
are you a gamer who wants to create a
world of your own then this is a game
you really don't want to miss
welcome to the world of brick city i'm
going to show you a world where your
creativity is humanity's last hope in
brick city you'll be helping the
survivors of humanity aka peoples return
to their home planet earth
a lot of things happened to our earth
and for 500 years the planet was no
place to live
humanity kind of felt responsible so
they invented a substance called bricks
we're still not quite sure how it works
but apparently bricks are full of power
and energy that can heal the earth
however that power can only be released
when fusing it with creative energy
that's where you enter the picture
you'll take on the role of a brix master
building your very own city out of
bricks and creativity
anything can be built using brakes the
only limit is your own imagination
you can also build using blueprints
either pre-made or designed by other
bricks masters
so pop in your creativity batteries and
the earth will be as good as new in no
time
oh another important thing what good is
a city without someone living there
human society has changed a lot the past
500 years now robots do all the work
while regular peoples chillax
but finally going back to our home
planet we want to mix things up a bit by
analyzing data remains from earth we've
gathered and educated people's willing
to work
the result now anyone can become a
doctor plumber tooth fairy dinosaur
wizard and more just like back in 2022
now your city is flourishing and
bustling with all the peoples living in
it what's next you ask just enjoy
yourself jump around the place reach for
the sky
talk with your fellow citizens because
why not
we can't wait to see what you'll make
using bricks
go for a stroll and enjoy your new life
on earth
stay tuned and follow us on social media
to find out more
as a six foot three inch man i've been
known to shoot some hoops now and then
not not in real life god know i'm
talking about video games and this next
game lets me handle a basketball while
traveling without getting a violation oh
we made it just in time for the sports
banner
where where have you been don't touch me
where have you been i'm british time
zones don't worry about it
tam you've lived in san francisco for
four years go dubs anyways here's the
latest from nba 2k
[Music]
now
[Music]
one down
[Music]
[Music]
we gonna flip the phone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
two
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
we gonna flip the phone
[Music]
three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
two
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
down
[Music]
it wouldn't be a video game showcase
without a just one more thing moment so
we've managed to line up a doozy this
next game is part of one of the biggest
video game franchises ever created and
as well as being massively popular on
console and pc it now has a huge
dedicated player base on mobile of
course we're talking about everyone's
favorite first person shooter the one
the only
call of duty
i
it's the one more thing moment
i've been waiting i've been
i've been waiting the
yikes
call of duty mobile is unique because it
really allows us to reach an entirely
different audience a much more globally
diverse audience season eight for this
year is the train of nowhere and this is
the first time we've ever done a spy
themed season it's really cool to kind
of imagine sort of going behind the rope
of
you know james bond universe and that
sort of trouble you can get into
in that sort of fantasy world the battle
pass features weapons like this zrg 20
millimeter bolt action sniper rifle
we have a all new spy
operators we have new season event
around called spy hunter there's a new
class in battle royale
that allows you to
also live out the spy fantasy so we're
really going deep with this integration
project aurora is our
next project in the call of duty mobile
ecosystem it's something we've been
taking all the learning from the past
several years operating call of duty
mobile learning what we wish we could do
if we were creating something new
looking what players really liked the
most and things that we maybe were never
really able to do in the first place the
first time around so that kind of
learning is precious and we have the
talent
the years of experience on operating
that style of game to open our eyes to
what's possible there's also a lot of
really cool innovation happening in the
call of duty franchise and you put those
two things together the learning that
we've had over the past uh several years
plus all the new evolutions that are
happening at call of duty franchise we
saw it as an opportunity to really bring
a next generation experience to mobile
players we have four internal studios
that are developing the title it's a lot
of really talented people from all
around the world at different studios
all coming together to make something
that really requires that level of
effort it's actually in a private alpha
right now so a lot of real players are
already helping us
by you know playing it every day and
giving us feedback to help improve it
the teams are right now you know play
testing and working every day to
continue to bring project aurora further
along
and we're excited to be able to show a
lot more about the project very very
soon our core experience here is to
bring warzone to mobile for the first
time um and that has a lot of
interesting challenges to it because the
scale and ambition that warzone has
always
had when it was first introduced and and
we want to do that justice i'm
happy to announce that the real title
for project aurora is call of duty
warzone mobile and you'll be able to see
more about that title live
at an event called next
which is a a call of duty franchise
event that's going to reveal the future
of call of duty um there's a lot of
exciting stuff that's going to happen
that's september 15th
you can go to the call of duty official
youtube channel or twitch to see it live
um we will be showing call of duty wars
on mobile there uh among many other uh
revelations so we're super excited to
announce the title and to show everybody
later this month
over the last few weeks you've been
voting on gamespot's social channels for
what you think is the greatest mobile
game of all time the list of contenders
included peggle hearthstone among us
florence monument valley and more it was
a hard fought battle to crown an
ultimate victor but we finally have won
the finals came down to pokemon go
versus that old classic snake and your
pick for the greatest mobile game of all
time was
snake that's right ladies and gentlemen
congrats to snake the nokia 6110s killer
app and thank you everyone for joining
us for the first ever gamespot swipe
mobile showcase hopefully you saw some
games that piqued your interest and had
a little fun watching too i want to take
a moment to thank all of our co-workers
who worked very hard on the show as well
as our partners that trusted us to show
off the games and their hardware
hopefully we'll be able to do this again
in the future thank you for watching
until next time see you later
you wrote this right yeah yeah yeah did
you notice that i didn't get to say
world premiere once i think that's a
jeff keeley thing and you do not want
the jeff keely smoke trust me
fair enough
nice job
yeah it went really well all right
sorry i won tim's calling cool yeah tim
what's up greg you're supposed to be
hosting kind of funny games daily with
me where are you tim you of all people
should know by now that remote work is
the way we're going to do this for the
rest of the world
you